this episode of versus was filmed prior
to the events of the 2022 oscar ceremony
with that knowledge in hand enjoy verses
hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that today pits two of
the hottest hunks in the history of
hollywood against each other because we
have tom cruise taking on will smith
they won't be here in studio obviously
not because they didn't want to be but
you got to have priorities in life and
tom is probably busy flying a jet or
dangling on the side of a cliff or
stealing his daddy's porsche for an
evening with rebecca de mourine will
smith also cannot be here because he'd
rather save the world from aliens save
miami from bad guys or save football
players from concussions but the good
news is i'm here
they don't let us out much i'm your host
mark ellis and what i may lack in fame i
more than make up for with my ability to
take two respectable resumes and make
them duke it out for all the glory duke
was maverick's dad's name and top gun i
also pepper in useless movie trivia
why should i know these things here's
how we'll determine a winner
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash audience score round three
memorable moments
round four versatility and then we'll do
a wild card round to settle the score
once and for all
i'm sorry did i properly introduce tom
and will do y'all you see usually on
this show i'll say in this corner it's
robocop and in the other corner it's
sonic the hedgehog but today
do i really need to it's tom cruise and
it's will smith one is known as mr
fourth of july and the other was born on
the fourth of july what are you talking
about okay well tom is in a movie called
that but did you know cruz's actual
birthday is july 3rd that's classified i
told you i got dumb trivia for days this
is going to be one of the most highly
debated outcomes in the history of the
world and this show but fear not i mark
ellis who is considered handsome when
i'm not standing next to a tom or a will
i'm sorry are you being funny but for
now it's just will and tom and there can
be only one of them let's get it on
we're gonna have a good time
round one box office
to say will smith and tom cruise do
pretty well at the box office is like
saying starbucks is pretty good at
selling coffee i'm the best
the entire movie theater industry has
thrived in large part due to the
continued attractions provided by will
and tom it is not a reach to say that
without smith and cruz movie theaters
would not exist as we know them today or
at the very least we'd have to make like
four transformers movies a year to make
up for their absence and nobody wants
that what we did and still do crave is
america's human autobot tom cruise and
it's been that way since the early 1980s
after appearing in modest hits like taps
and the outsiders crews shifted into
third gear with 1983's risky business a
coming-of-age comedy that grows 63
million dollars worldwide then that gear
shift turned into a jet engine that
sounded a lot like kenny loggins when
top gun buzzed our collective tower in
may of 1986. the film would go on to
amass 357 million dollars around the
globe even though the other side denies
the incident completely
sorry the movie is like one long
memorable quote so you're going to be
hearing a lot of those this is what i
call a target rich environment will
smith isn't exactly flying rubber dog
poop out of hong kong either as the
fresh prince struck it big on the silver
screen right out of the gate he got big
laughs and stole scenes in the 1993
whoopi goldberg ted danson comedy made
in america which did over 100 million
dollars in cash register jingles two
years later will smith launched a movie
theater sprint that turned into a run
and it's now just a marathon that keeps
turning out baffo box office bad boys
drew 141 million dollars worldwide in
1995 and smith would go on to see
16 of his next 18 starring roles gross
at least a hundred million dollars at at
most 817 million courtesy of
independence day
that's great that's fine that stood as
will's standard setter until 2019 when a
kid rubbed a lamp out came aladdin and
cleaned up to the tune of over one
billion dollars worldwide so tom cruise
has been running in movies for over 40
years and his multiplex receipts have
kept the pace beginning with 1992's a
few good men and it's 236 million dollar
haul
i'm pacing myself cruz would see 14 of
his next 15 movies taking at least 100
million dollars one more i get a set of
steak knives and the only outlier was
magnolia a film in which he did earn an
oscar nomination fun fact will smith jog
also took a break from the triple
million figures for ali when he secured
an oscar nomination so look we're either
raking it in at the theaters or we're
getting a sweet oscar swag bag without
me you'd be a tall white man with a
microphone in his mouth cruz hasn't
soared to the billion dollar heights
that smith has seen but tom's mission
impossible franchise continually churns
out gigantic hits he's been over the 600
million dollar line three times all
thanks to his choosing to accept a
mission and the all-time high bar is
currently set with fallout which is the
fifth of those impossibles i think i
don't know they all run together and
they're all great
[Music]
both stars can do it all they can lead
an independent film to award show glory
starring a standalone hit or create a
franchise capable of sending stock
markets to the moon but while tom cruise
has made more total coin in his career
at a current score of 10.74 billion to
will smith's 9.59 billion it is the
prince who takes the throne when it
comes to per movie average will smith
vehicles earn an average of 309 million
dollars per outing the average tom
cruise movie enjoys a 250 million dollar
tick
this is too much money i why am i
talking about this we should have hired
one of those rich movie guys like a
michael douglas or richard gere to talk
about the numbers in this round would
you actually stop talking long enough
for me to answer me i'm just hoping i
recoup that eighty dollars i sunk into
crypto thanks matt damon positive
positive thinking it's will smith that
by the law of averages gets a narrow
victory over tom cruise in round one but
much like vincent in collateral we're
gonna be here a while and the night's
just getting warmed up just flowing with
my work
round two tomato meter slash audience
score sure any good looking stud can
trip into a box office smash or two but
it takes more than star power to
continue to put butts in seats for a
combined 70 years you gotta consistently
crank out quality product and that's
exactly what will and tom have done in
their time think of all the scripts that
they've been offered all the meetings
that they've taken all the lunches that
they've
launched not to change the subject or
anything but when was the last time you
had a cat scan when they finally decided
their next project it's not just movie
theater owners to get excited it's the
critics too
we'll see about that both william and
tomas have made some stellar cinema
that's rated near the top of the tomato
meter i'm not talking about you wild
wild west we'll get to you in a moment
take a number have a seat i stand before
you as a man realizing that i have done
something wrong i was thinking more
about men in black at 92 percent or king
richard at 90 i'm in the champion
raising business and one of smith's
earliest roles was in six degrees of
separation and that's at 88 percent
whereas the very recent bad boys for
life is also fresh at 76 percent
but there are some duds marring this
glowing report card and yes wild wild
west now you may step into my office
it's at 17
that's the bad news the good news at
least for that movie is that there's two
flicks below it on will smith's tomato
meter you care to guess no comment
collateral beauty is at 14
i barely have heard of it after earth is
the low bar at 11
i think i liked it i'm quietly judging
you i saw it once haven't thought about
it since but come on it's got to be
better than
www yeah
i blew that one and now we pivot to tom
cruise and remember those mission
impossible popcorn chompers well the
critics love them some buttery treats
too and it's fallout at 97 percent that
leads both gentlemen at the top rogue
nation is at 94 and goes protocols at 93
percent but the guy's not a one-trick
pony he's got risky business at 92
percent minority reported 90
and they sandwiched 91
edge of tomorrow
unfortunately for that attempted launch
of a dark universe there was no tomorrow
tom's the mummy is at 16
and his all-time lowest film is 7
christ
it gives me absolutely no pleasure to
reveal that that fine piece of seven
percent cinema is
cocktail take the check and get out of
my daughter's life i'm doing the best i
can okay
here's a hot take i kind of side with
elizabeth shu's father in that movie
don't throw your life away on some gin
jockey you met the bahamas no offense
taken in case you're wondering wait a
decade and just do the same thing with
nicolas cage in las vegas all right so
the critics have had their say now let's
tune into the audience score frequency
curiously tom and will flip-flop at the
top on this metric as it's king richard
at 98 percent that owns the number one
spot bad boys for life aladdin and spies
in disguise all top tom cruise's best
effort with the crowd which is edge of
tomorrow with dire repeat whatever it's
called at 90 percent that's tied with
rain man the movie that reminded us all
how dustin hoffman really feels about
kmart k-mart sucks a few good men is at
89 percent interview with the vampires
86 percent and top gun is at 83 percent
which exacts some measure of revenge
because on the tomato meter the greatest
naval aviation slash volleyball film of
all time is at the space ball's number
of 59
it's so close to fresh that one percent
sucks doesn't it if goose pulled through
in that movie i'm pretty sure we're
looking at what 93 94 95 percent fresh
you're a lot brighter than you look will
smith's lowest mark with the customers
is wild wild west at 28
tom cruises is the mummy at 32
but cruz has a few more flicks weighing
him down here at 42 percent is mission
impossible too which despite metallica
rocking the soundtrack is the only mi
film to disappear from freshness into
rotten ground that movie is tied with
jack reacher never go back and that
contributes to tom's 68 audience score
average which is bested by will smith's
bill and ted approved 69
average excellent
but it's tom cruise who gets a
definitive win in the veggie patch as
his per film tomato meter average is 64
fresh besting will smith's rotten but
still respectable 52
and that will prove to be the difference
in this round cruz had all the right
moves which is at 63 percent causing
will smith to momentarily lose focus at
56 percent and if you can't tell um i
really like these guys in their movies
together with the token might get me on
a subway round three memorable moments
it's not a question of if will smith and
tom cruise have created noteworthy
sequences in their careers it's just a
matter of what was your first time
seeing these dudes on the big screen and
saying wow that's a great moment it
ain't hyperbolic to proclaim that these
two a-listers may have created the most
memorable scenes of any two careers in
tinseltown history for me i'm a man of
some decades myself so tom cruise came
on my radar first with the smash hit top
gun
[Music]
i was just a wee lad so i missed it in
theaters but my vhs tape filled with
high flying fighter jet action and goose
keeping up foreign relations you know
the finger got worn out in my household
rather fast thank you showtime free
preview weekend you have wisdom behind
your ears for will smith i was coming
into my own as a high school freshman
when bad boys hit and i was thrilled to
see the star of the best sitcom of the
1990s in an r-rated action film i'm of
course talking about martin lawrence go
back and watch the sitcom martin it was
legendary thoughtful will smith being a
badass in that film took me by a mild
surprise but i totally bought into him
as a cool cop with a wild streak which
begs the question who runs better is it
cruz at sprint speed or smith in michael
bay slo-mo meanwhile movies like king
richard and rain man don't need to rely
on loads of shootouts and special
effects to create lifelong memories
just examine will smith's compassionate
yet strict father figure to the williams
sisters and his verbal jousting with
john bernthal is also a highlight tom
cruise was still hot off a top gun in
1988 but charlie babbitt in rain man
elevated his thespian stature to another
level as he shows the frustration of
dealing with a special needs brother at
the same time we see his emotionally
stifled elation at the mere discovery
that he has a sibling we'd see more
evidence of this acting ability in court
when cruz went toe-to-toe with kevin
bacon head-to-head with keeper
sutherland and quote for quote with jack
nicholson you want answers i think i'm
entitled you want answers i want the
truth you can't handle the truth
both these fellows can handle kick-ass
action scenes and we'll get to some of
those electrifying moments in a bit but
let's not forget their sheer ability to
nail a dramatic take will smith's chris
gardner finally getting a job in the
pursuit of happiness or tom cruise
bawling his eyes out as frank mackey and
magnolia comedy has also been a genre of
note for both the expectations
subverting les grossman and tropic
thunder is still some of the best
dancing you'll see in movie history and
will smith lights up the screen as a
confident player who's befuddled by eva
mendes in hitch
oscar glory had eluded smith until
winning for king richard but his take on
ali was a transcendent effort simply
because we knew muhammad ali and will
smith so well tom cruise similarly
disappeared into the role of vietnam vet
ron kovic holding in a rage that would
only occasionally come out through eyes
speech or body language all right enough
of this real stuff let's save the world
a few dozen times we don't negotiate
with terrorists
if top gun and independence day are just
one long quotable endlessly entertaining
memorable moment then we could also look
to the bad boys and mission impossible
franchises for scintillating sequences
the clan infiltration that opens bad
boys too as a highlight as is anytime
mike and marcus flemix joey pants to the
point where he doesn't know what to do
with himself or a basketball anymore
it's the ultimate loose cannons costing
the city's millions of dollars a damage
buddy cop ride and we are all in why
because it's will and martin and briefly
dan marino let me know how it rides oh
he gonna test drive this out there
mission impossible always does just that
as tom cruise finds a way to top himself
and his stunts with each subsequent
entry sometimes even at the cost of his
own rib ribcage tom we love you we beg
you you don't have to jump over
buildings i promise we'll still see the
movie but if you want to dangle on the
side of maybe the world's tallest
structure
okay i'll let you do that ghost protocol
was still my favorite mission impossible
movie for that sequence but i also give
props to tom for when he held on to dear
life as a plane was taking off or a
bridge explosion rocked him into several
cars at part three or the cliffhanger
opening of mi2 i think he's
got a little out of hand but you know
what still gets me the most the end
fight of mission impossible 2 when de
gray scott gets this close to stabbing
ethan hunt in the eye that's a real
knife kids don't try it at home it was
attached to a string measured to stop
less than a centimeter away from movie
star tom cruise's eye
maybe he booked that role in valkyrie
just in case it went wrong
will smith has personality to burn and
it shows in the men in black films he's
funny slick intelligent and good-looking
all while saving the planet
i make this look good tom cruise doesn't
have the luck that will had when he was
in war of the worlds as most of his
humans are turned into literal spaghetti
but then we tennis it back to will for
the ultimate we saved the world as
billions of people died movie
independence day his lines like i have
got to give me one of these and welcome
to earth are iconic hell even has his
own show named after that last one and
the sheer amount of extraterrestrial
damage inflicted on our globe's most
precious structures still holds up
however the wind in this round goes to
the sports agent that completed us the
pool hustler of a new generation and the
nascar hero who could do anything in a
race car including turning a rental car
into a race car then sprinting on the
beach against his arch nemesis days of
thunder's awesome you sure make a lot of
mistakes for a so-called educated man
round four versatility
there may not be anything tc legend
can't do in a race car but how is he
fair inside of a blockbuster video now
usually this is the part of the show
where i have to remind you youngsters
what a blockbuster was but today i'm
going to use my soapbox for a different
purpose the nickname tc legend is just
the worst it's stupid and it's tom
cruise and i get it he was in a movie
called legend but mr fourth of july
that's what i call a nickname volume one
van damme is the muscles from brussels
but we can't get a solid nickname for
tom cruise fine i'm calling him maverick
i will not say tc legend again but will
smith was great and i am legend which
could be in the horror section of a
blockbuster if they still existed hey
who's the girl
never mind there's some sci-fi in action
in that movie but i consider it a horror
classic and that's what this round is
all about how many tools you all got in
those swiss army knives you call a
career tom and will can do it all but
who's better at the totality of that all
any of that makes sense it's too late
your host m.e legend is gonna roll with
it you really are not that guy despite
the solid interview with the vampire
will gets the edge in scary movies with
that i am legend deal although you could
consider war of the worlds to be
horrific you know what i'm going to put
that in the sci-fi section where tom
also has edge of tomorrow to his credit
and oblivion to his detriment i know
some of y'all liked it i kind of fell
asleep will smith might take this
section of hollywood video as well but
that's only because of the massive hit
that was id4 oh no wait he's also got
the comedic science fiction entries men
in black and even though i hated the
third movie it's a gigantic pain in the
ass
but it has its moments it wasn't his
fault it was that annoying alien griff
played by the otherwise wonderful
michael stoolbark stoolbarge i love
griff i'll never forgive anything's
possible will smith also has another
sci-fi movie i liked irobot and i'm the
guy that cared for after earth so
what the hell do i know let's just let
me make the big decisions okay let's go
to action i am well versed in that and
even without tom cruise's very hard
mission movies he makes a great case
here valkyrie the last samurai
collateral the first jack reacher kinda
he's got some big action hits will smith
can counter though with the bad boys
movies enemy of the state hancock and
suicide squad in which he was great but
i'm gonna give tom the w in the action
section thanks to those other six i
think soon to be seven mission
impossibles are the really hard stunts
that he has to pull off let's just go
back to remember mission impossible one
remember how it all started they killed
emilio estevez in an elevator shaft
dramas might go to cruz as well though
smith has a strong case here because
this is where all of his oscar glory has
come from ali and the pursuit of
happiness got him nominations king
richard scored the win and concussion
had a strong case although his doctor
bennett omalu came up just short in a
crowded field but tom cruise has his
nominations in this section as well we
got born on the fourth of july jerry
maguire and magnolia all making for
solid dramatic fare but whereas will
smith front loads this genre with
academy awards gold tom cruise goes deep
with a few good men taps vanilla sky the
color of money american made and rain
man there's no need to consult judge
watner for this ruling cruz wins the
drama category i'm happy to entertain
you but here comes will smith and comedy
the guy is legit hilarious and he
probably would have been a hugely
successful stand-up comic if that's what
he wanted to do i'll give major points
to his hit sitcom the fresh prince of
bel-air a mythology that still has fresh
legs all these years later bye
george i think he's got it and then he
can go the rom-com route with hitch the
family route with aladdin or the
unintentional comedy route of wild wild
west look we expect will to deliver the
yucks but with tom cruise it's more
funny because he plays so against type
as the portly slob less grossman or even
when he has a tinier cameo in films like
austin powers in gold member yeah baby
and that's really what this round
ultimately comes down to tom cruise is
best when he's serious and focused and
that allows him to surprise us when he
shows the softer side in films like
jerry maguire or even magnolia will
smith naturally gives us a good time
regardless of what he's doing and we
don't really care about the genre look i
saw i am legend and i wanted to live in
a zombie apocalypse with my dog after
seeing will and his german shepherd then
the second half of that movie happened
and i reconsidered my take but if we're
talking versatility will smith has to
get the nod because he can also score
his own movies men in black wild wild
west a multi-platinum music career
outside of the scope of cinema prove he
can do anything he puts his mind to so
while i do give tom cruise a heaping
dose of musical credit for his role as
stacy jackson rock of ages tom's musical
talent is the goose to will smith's
maverick it can't be too soon that
happened in 1986 will gets the win here
and we're tied 2-2 you can clap now
[Music]
and now it's time for the wild card
round run forest run
all due respect to mr gump and his
exploits on the alabama crimson tide
gridiron but not even forests run back
and forth across america could equal the
total amount of steps that tom cruise
and will smith have gotten in on the big
screen so after all the box office
positive reviews and iconic sequences
that have every nook and cranny of your
local video store covered the winner of
this match will be determined by who the
best runner in the history of movies is
it's either tom or will i can hold my
own so my first blush image of will
smith running is his treadmill set up
with his best pal and i am legend you
see outside there's walkers so maybe
getting in shape inside the friendly
confines of your apartment is the safe
play for cruz it's the breakneck speed
of his sprints in the mission impossible
films that are the opening salvo dude
runs everywhere and unlike certain other
actors looking at you harrison thinking
about you liam we really do believe tom
is hauling ass like deion sanders
however the running from will smith and
bad boys is poetry in motion now sure
michael bay loves his slow-mo as much as
anyone not named john woo but i don't
care about the billowing trench coats or
the slow head turns give me will under
the bridging his way on the big screen
running away from or towards danger as i
shovel popcorn into my face and i'm in
hog heaven will gets additional points
for enemy of the state a movie that sees
him running for the bulk of the two-hour
run time and the pursuit of happiness in
which there's a clip called running if
you're rooting for tom cruise today
you're probably shouting from your
treadmill come on this is the guy that's
known for running at the cinema to which
i'd reply you're right when he's not
singing free falling in a car he ain't
just jogging he's going all out he can
do a dead sprint like in mission
possible three
or pretty much all the other ones he can
also do confused running like in vanilla
sky when he's the only one in times
square meaning maybe him and will smith
and the german shepherd can hang out
anyway he also outran aliens in war of
the worlds and not the slow ones michael
myers can outrun e.t but to sprint away
from athletic otherworldly beings is a
feat fit for a king the best of will
smith working out might be an ali and if
you've ever met a boxer you know they
spend tons of time getting that road
work in training for a match against a
george foreman or joe frazier is intense
but so is whatever crazy assignment
ethan hunt said yes to he's running at
bad guys he's running away from his own
agencies or up the side of a building
there's no type of running that tom
cruise can't do he can even do the
extremely difficult should be an olympic
event suit run like in the firm when he
is running full tilt while in a sport
coat tie in slacks
it's a tough call here and will smith
puts up a great fight against the most
famous sprinter in movie history so we
go to twitter to settle this score
no i was too lazy to do a poll but i did
go to tom cruise's official twitter
account which states that he's been
running in movies since 1981. so he even
has a sense of humor about it and he
produced the film without limits about
the legendary distance runner steve
prefontaine never heard of him look the
dude up i call him sp legend tom cruise
gets to win in the wild card round and
thus takes the match
in 10 000 years
i've never been that embarrassed and
here's why i love doing this show much
like a great basketball bracket
tournament anything can happen on any
given day will smith defeated denzel
washington last season on this show tom
cruise just beat will smith so does that
mean tom could take out denzel uh not so
fast denzel doesn't need to run in
movies did you all see the equalizer he
just sets a stopwatch 30 seconds later
everyone in the room is dead from a
broken neck
it's fun stuff as always this is all
just my opinion and think of this vid as
a conversation starter who would you
take which movie star's next project you
most anticipate everybody knows that i
am the champ let me know with your vote
on social media at mark ellis live and
be sure to stay tuned right here at
rotten tomatoes for all the latest in
movies tv and some fun debates therein
thanks for watching versus i'm mark
ellis and i definitely can't handle the
truth but i'll tell it i will tell the
truth
you